el Parque del retiro vuelve a
convertirse en una gran librería al aire
libre con el inicio de la feria del
libro de Madrid la mayor del país que
este año llega a su edición 82 y que
estará abierta hasta el 11 de junio sin
la presencia de un país invitado de
honor simplemente pasear y estar rodeado
de libros es una manera muy atractiva de
pasar la mañana principalmente ahora hoy
a novelas gráficas que les veo y me
gusta tenerlas en físico porque así veo
las ilustraciones y veo un poquillo más
allá que no solo digital a mí me encanta
la aventura y el misterio de hecho unos
libros que se llaman los hijos de la
tierra que son te mezcla aventura con la
Prehistoria entonces aprendes un montón
este año haciendo previsión de las altas
temperaturas y por petición popular se
han instalado varias lonas para crear
sombra en los pasillos culturales sin
embargo por ahora este fin de semana
inaugural Parece que va a estar pasado
por agua esto no ha impedido Que varios
lectores se acerquen a visitar las 385
casetas en las que unas mil editoriales
muestran sus libros este año por primera
vez la iniciativa indómitas que pretende
cambiar la idea del formato habitual de
un libro
editoriales que trabajan en lo no
convencional y que buscan un poco en el
libro y en el objeto Un fin en sí mismo
es una forma de que todo el mundo
aprendamos de que no todo hay que seguir
la Norma y que hay otras formas de
hacerlas la autointuición es otra
alternativa que tenemos en el mundo de
la literatura y es otro campo al que no
hay que tapar y hay que mirar porque es
muy importante para el autor sobre todo
para iniciarse cinco mil actos de firmas
de autores seminarios con enfoque
latinoamericano actividades que incluyen
hasta partidos de fútbol o de ajedrez y
una visita al interior del cerebro
humano y es que la ciencia es la
temática que vertebra esta feria del
libro de Madrid cuyo lema este año es
somos de ciencias y de letras la feria
espera superar los tres millones de
visitantes que tuvo en 2022